what does it say that this key element
of Witchcraft is now effectively
ubiquitous that porn is just everywhere
if sexual immorality is a big part of
Witchcraft in the occult well what what
does the rapid expansion of that say if
we go back to the Bible and we talk
about the jeze spirit she was a witch
right she was immoral so she was
involved in sexual immorality so she was
released over a place demons Don't Walk
Alone the principalities they don't walk
by themselves as I said we were talking
about authorities and they move with
with certain powers that come under them
and then they have others that come
under them witchcraft which is a new age
occultism all all of these practices
Satanism all of these things bring
sexual immorality so now because of the
occultism is rapidly spanding in our
Nations we see the sexual immorality
also being released Upon Our Nations